in April this professional streamer had
more social media interactions than
LeBron James Cristiano Ronaldo and
Shaquille O'Neal making him the most
popular athlete in the world he also
makes more than $500,000 a month jumping
off a virtual bus onto an island to farm
fight loot and dance with 99 other
players in a fight to the death and he
generally wins a lot he's played
alongside the likes of Drake Travis
Scott and a number of professional
athletes that's kind of me
right there to the right he's raised
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
charity I'm saying if we do first day
ten ten thousand shirts then the rest is
like five thousand a day and we make it
that's what it is ten thousand the first
day five thousand combined for the rest
and like a day and even hosted his own
eSports event that broke the twitch
viewership record he set when he played
with the six god Vegas 18 I'm super
excited to get started this is ninja and
if you don't recognize his face yet
it'll only be a matter of time until you
do but where did this guy come from
and how did he carry the gaming world
out of tilted towers
[Music]
kawaski Adele kills right here this is
his story
[Music]
Tyler ninja Blevins started his eSports
career in Halo just as halo 3 was coming
out and made his East worst debut at MLG
Orlando 2009 with team four of a kind
only 19 at the time Ninja made a name
for himself as an aggressive player
whose risky play style quickly became
his calling card I knew right away like
this kid is going to be amazing he's got
a lot a lot of talent you just basically
have to run with him because he is just
going to hold forward get in people's
faces and challenge and just you know he
was he was a 1v1 god he was that very
individually based player but it was
only when Halo Reach came out in
September 2010 that ninja truly
flourished and quickly rose to the upper
echelon of reach players they're kind of
like impact here a lot of people not
giving them the credit they deserve I
couldn't agree more to their Chris and
the thing is if you have a player like
ninja on their team who is going to
spark he's got so much individual talent
and status quo although they have a lot
of teamwork aren't necessarily the best
shots so ninja could really disturb this
damn ninja bounce between various teams
between 2010 and 2012 but was picked up
by final boss at the end of 2011 in the
world of Halo eSports playing for final
boss was as big as it gets
and when they picked up ninja everyone
knew just how good he was
keeping constant pressure he is trying
to Spartan his team to get another five
caps so much he's doing everything in a
tower someone on final boss Maggie I got
a ninja on the flank there it comes in
with the backpack don't for backpack
number two omits trying to sail out
victory gets the flag back to his base
keeping that one a lot great play here
out of all four members of final boss
and ninja is gonna put it in as FB take
game number one shortly after he joined
final boss the scene swish from reach to
Halo four it was in that game that he
finally won it all like this game is
gonna be over solids is a long map to
run the flagon I don't think it is even
possible to run two flags on his nose
and the flares are standing up there is
the congratulation give it up for your
warrior squad MLG first-ever Halo four
champion
and as he took the halo scene by storm
ninja was also streaming on Twitch even
at the beginning of his streaming career
when he was only broadcasting to a
handful of viewers it was clear that he
was at his best in front of an audience
ballsy move are here by me
he lets him get the freaking camouflaged
shop behind him but a double no scope
rocket your UPS todo that's very
important
after Halo four came halo 2 anniversary
during which ninja competed with cloud 9
he put up a string of strong finishes
highlighted by a top four finish at HCS
season one finals ninja finishes halo
career during Halo 5 he played on Team
Liquid renegades evil geniuses and a
luminosity during that era his last
major event as a halo player was
Dreamhack Atlanta 2017 with luminosity
while he was playing with evil geniuses
he continued to play halo but was
balancing it with his new love h1z1 the
zombie style battle royale game helped
ninja stream take off in a big way
[Music]
he was able to make the jump from an
eSports player styling in his game of
choice to a full-time entertainer
playing the hot new game making a small
little break ski from from halo focusing
more on other games and streaming ninja
stream began to grow larger during the
summer of 2017 after the release of
player unknowns battlegrounds pub G made
a huge splash in the streaming world the
battle royale format was perfect for
crazy highlights funny moments and an
all-around viewer experience streamers
flocked to the game to keep up with its
rising popularity the skills that ninja
picked up from his Halo days serve him
well and to an extent transferred to
this new format
[Music]
no matter what the objective of the game
is one thing started to become clear
ninja was lethal with a rifle
[Music]
and when fortnight battle royale was
released in September 2017 that kid who
would play halo wearing a cow on his
head would never be the same on October
3rd 2017 ninja streamed fortnight for
the first time but unlike his dreams now
his average viewership stayed steady at
around 5,000 and then as December reared
its frosty head ninja stream blew up
12,000 viewers in December 2017 turned
into 25,000 in January and by the time
spring came around he was streaming to a
hundred thousand viewers a day no it's
so crazy man the times just changed so
much especially since like I'm an
uncharted territory as a streamer I
always valued and I took pride in the
fact that like I always read every 7
every dono and unfortunately I had to
cut out reading subs because there's
just way too many like you know here we
are you know about a month maybe two
months in where I haven't read subs and
you know you're complimenting me on
reading all the dough knows right like
it's not always my best make shot I
never missed them a former halo pro
turned small-time streamer was climbing
to the top of the twitch viewership
rankings and he was hauling fortnight
along with him what's unique about
ninjas on-screen persona is that he's
able to effectively combine the
attitudes and styles of several twitch
personality archetypes he can be
boisterous and loud
he's dodging him oh he can impress you
with his play skill and ingame advice
yeah just don't get lazy with them and
rely on building you and going like
they're literally only relying on
shooting they're very slowly sound like
they're building is not very clear once
the help hear me always your teaching
always getting better in that situation
when you're that weak going up one and
then looking to shoot it's like like go
up to go with two or three before you do
that right because like only one that
means that that means that a bad player
all ESU is his ramp on one time walk-up
and now he's on that level with you you
don't even like it you want to make him
think make him make make them make them
make a good play he can catch the eyes
of parents with his rants about the
importance of education commitment to
charity and focus on mental health
awareness and honestly I encourage
everyone to do that all the kids out
there like you you can't just drop
everything and focus on playing video
games for a living it's also becoming a
very competitive career choice right now
and you want to make sure that you're
you know you're securing your future and
putting in the extra time to try to make
this happen as well he has the skills
needed to both capture an audience and
keep them coming back
day after day and I literally remember
the turning point of my entire career
was when I address my stream and I was
just like you need to understand that I
love this game but like a lot of these
people who are watching me play for and
I like no one is like supporting the
channel no one is subscribing
I can't keep playing this game if you
guys don't support me and that day alone
I think I gained like a thousand
subscribers and then after that it was
over at the time ninja stream started to
grow battle royale games were still
relatively in their infancy and in a lot
of ways for tonight's success has gone
hand in hand with the ninjas growth as a
streamer it's been interesting to see
the way that he's grown
and for night has been very successful
for him people enjoy watching him
because he is terrifyingly good
something I don't tell him a little
jealous it's sometimes I look at it I
think man did epic just make this game
specifically for him his personality on
stream and the way that the game is
played adda at a higher entertainment
style thing of that those two those two
things that go hand-in-hand has he got
better more people watched him and more
people played fortnight and when he
became one of the best players in the
world fortnight lept into the mainstream
in a big way everyone was freaking out
that the big video game publishers were
in the crosshairs of these popular new
battle royal / style
morley player games this fortnight this
is a new game called fortnight is
drawing millions of players flips now
talk fortnight shall we it's the newest
video game craze spreading across fast
among kids college kids even celebrities
and we've seen him capitalize on that by
expanding his reach within the fortnight
ecosystem ninjas brought streaming
personalities like myth dr. Lupo and Tim
the tap man into his bubble of
popularity and helped them grow
alongside him just as he drops the
Micheel potion in game he'll also plug
their stream with his growing popularity
his posse his famous win streak headband
and that catchy ponpon dance
[Music]
ninjas built a stream that feels close
to a sitcom and ninja is the fearless
protagonist saving his teammates that
tilted towers and cracking jokes
amidst the familiar backdrop of his
basement guest bedroom February song
ninja averaged more than 46,000 viewers
at a time making him one of the top
streamers in the world he'd climbed the
ladder to the pinnacle of the gaming
world at the top of the twitch rankings
but on March 14th 2018 ninja proved that
he wasn't going to settle for being
twitches flavor of the month it was time
to break out of the gaming echo chamber
ninja plates squads with rappers Drake
and Travis Scott as well as Pittsburgh
Steelers wide receiver juju Smith
Schuester and well it kind of broke the
internet anyway how you boys doing great
you guys get enough crab good this
insane yeah the stream broke the twitch
individual streaming record with around
six hundred and thirty thousand
concurrent viewers in just one night
ninja became a household name and his
viewership ballooned during March ninjas
streamed to over 90,000 viewers every
day he had Drake on for a second stream
then he got a I mean I did you gotta put
some fortnight lingo I'm it has to
happen it's just got to be the right way
I'm gonna pull it out absolutely I say
when epic gives me the emo when epic is
in the hotline bling' emote all boo
and all of a sudden every twitch viewer
consumer of pop culture and their
extended family knew who ninja was so
what's different about a ninja stream
now that he's sitting in his basement in
front of 100,000 viewers all the time
ninja sees the relationship between
viewer and streamer unlike any other
absolutely like someone I did a recent
interview and that was one of their
questions was like am I am I would I
consider myself like a personality or a
character and absolutely not I'm the
exact same person I have never seen a
harder worker in my mind it goes back to
the guy that was like I have to be on
for these 600 subs and he's the same
person and it's just paid off he
provides a social contract he's willing
to communicate honestly in a way that
feels sincere in exchange for viewership
and subscription he makes you feel like
an integral part of the community he's
building and for that your money feels
well-spent
ninjas the good guy the guy you'd want
to show to your parents to defend the
time you spend playing for at night
believe in yourself and work hard know
what you're worth know what you're
capable of resilience very important but
someone you can also kick back and watch
with your friends
you
you
all of this combined with his consistent
streaming schedule and clear focus on
having a unified brand has led to his
success oh yeah did we mention that he's
one of the best four night players in
the world
oh my god like the LeBron
what you mention
[Music]
at the end of April ninja continued to
add to his story few months with ninja
Vegas his own $50,000 foreign aid
tournament at the eSports Arena in Las
Vegas the event pitted ninja against
some of the game's best where players
receive $2,500 for killing ninja and
$2,500 for a victory royale still pretty
important before this continued in ten
flights over two days for a total of
$50,000 in prizes and anytime ninja won
$2,500 would be donated to the
Alzheimer's Association
[Applause]
to say that it was a massive success
would be an understatement
not only was it the first major
competitive Fortnight event but at one
point it had more than six hundred and
sixty seven thousand concurrent viewers
surpassing the famous Drizzy stream
charitable endeavors like this have
become a staple of ninja's rise to the
top he seems to be doing a new charity
stream or initiative every other week
seventy seventy four thousand six
hundred and fifty five dollars in nine
hours I mean that's about tagging out
10k an hour inking out that's incredible
man you guys are amazing in the past he
spent time raising money to support
suicide awareness and the Alzheimer's
Association what we have done and
accomplished today is remarkable I mean
I can't lie there's nothing more to say
in under eight hours we have raised a
hundred and thirteen thousand dollars
and it was more recently he sold branded
t-shirts in collaboration with streamer
and duo's partner dr. Lupo combined they
set out to raise five hundred thousand
dollars for st. Jude's Research Hospital
so here we are in 2018 and so far this
month an X halo Pro turned battle royale
streamer is streaming to an average of
over 125 thousand people every day and
he isn't slowing down
[Music]
are you in March 2018 Hughes ranked
third in the world in social
interactions
right behind Cristiano Ronaldo and
LeBron James this was the first time a
pro gamer cracked the top ten of this
list in April he was the number one
ranked athlete in the world on the same
chart as of mid-may he has almost 7
million twitch followers more than 10
million YouTube subscribers and over 2
million Twitter followers it feels like
he's streaming with or making
appearances with the most famous people
in the world on a weekly basis he's a
household name in the truest sense the
amalgamation of every gaming meets
mainstream story line combined
despite its stranglehold on the gaming
world it's still unclear just how far
fortnight will go the competitive
landscape is mostly made up of
third-party and community events one of
these events May's keemstar tournament
proved just how lethal ninja could be in
a competitive environment
[Music]
keep getting lit
just days after that event Epic Games
announced a jaw-dropping 100 million
dollar commitment to competitive
fortnight events during the 2018-2019
season meaning that 490 sports is likely
to take off in a big way being that
there's like 100 million dollars in the
prize pool now are you gonna try to make
some money off of it I feel like I would
have better luck doing just about
anything than making money so you don't
think it's a file option for people
unless you're like the best game in the
world right yeah that's you know would
be good pretty good at it on Tuesday May
1st he streamto 190,000 people just
after the newest fortnight season
started almost two hundred thousand
people watched ninja play fortnight on a
regular boring Tuesday afternoon it's
all happening right in front of our eyes
the craziest part about it is that it's
still growing
with no signs of slowing down
[Music]
Oh God
[Music]
- I said one
you bet
he's gonna throw stickers I think that
that literal one match with Drake made
it okay for everyone to live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]